when tommy told you about steve
how long did it take for you to actually
meet him like where did you guys first
meet
uh it was mayor june i want to say june
yeah june of 97. it was when it wasn't
it wasn't long after the surf expo then
tommy was like
like couple weeks or something like
tommy got you out like he was like
it was it was a few months but as soon
as i met danny
i think that there was some other guys
on the team too like the xyz team danny
was on board
tommy's on board but the idea that this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
who sets himself on fire is on the team
list he's not even a skater
was kind of offensive to some of the
other team guys and so when
uh when when they flew me out to san
diego
it was like all right and i'm going to
meet everybody and these guys are kind
of looking at me
like [ __ ] sideways a little bit you
know like oh like what the [ __ ]
so what are you doing you're just like
smashing beer bottles in your head
right and uh and and everybody was
hanging out [ __ ] uh
you know in danny's living room [ __ ]
doing bong hits
and i was at genre it was my friend's
house by the way okay
my house was a little bit more
controlled environment but
that scene was like dude just a couch of
people doing bong hits all day long
right okay but but everybody's around it
was like you know a bunch of guys on the
team and it was like
[ __ ] like i grabbed the bong and and
[ __ ] just
not knock it back i drink all the bong
water put it down empty
and like then everyone's like all right
we get it
like that kind of went i think that that
won everybody over
a little bit stevo came in and like was
like hey what's up what's up steve steve
steve and then like
oh can i get a bong hit like
and this wasn't just a normal bong hit
these guys were smoking mall hits all
day with tobacco in there so like the
water was pretty
you know it was pretty murky with just
like you know
nicotine like i never i think they were
using heart rules and [ __ ] back then
dude so like i'm sure there was a bunch
of chemicals and [ __ ] in that water
and that bong wasn't cleaned it was so
dirty steve comes in
sits down and asks for bongit and we're
like sure packing them
all hit rips the thing holds it in for a
second
then chugs the [ __ ] bomb on water and
then blows out the hit
and we were just like what dude no way
he didn't he didn't claim anything he
didn't like he didn't promote this he
just sat down and did it
and like whoa dude it was this guy this
is crazy
and then uh i think it was like the next
day dude he was doing you know
gainers fireball gainers off the
trestles
with handcuffs on into the into the into
the um
you know lagoon it was the fire
breathing the handcuffed fire breathing
gainer flip off the bridge was my first
xyz yet
and that's what we shot on that trip
that's sick i don't know if i ever saw
that one
handcuffed yeah handcuffed and then and
the cops came
we lit the whole fight with the top of
the bridge was like train tracks and it
was like all wood like
i needed a good amount of fire to set
myself on fire to do the fire breathing
flip
and so the cops saw this fire on the
[ __ ] bridge and they come down and
they're like oh
[ __ ] so like the the xyz
clothing receptionist they had like this
hot chick and they took the tape and
like stuffed it in her bra
and we're like oh we don't know dude
what [ __ ] we came here to film in the
[ __ ] we forgot the tape
yeah how i mean how many times before
that have you drinking bong water at
parties was that like a weekly thing or
is that like
impr it wasn't like super rare but
that's
that was a special occasion kind of
trick did you know you're going to do
that before or you're like
i got to do something yeah i don't think
i knew i was going to do that before but
it was a big deal for me to meet danny
did you know
like danny from like
he was my childhood hero yeah
dude